if you look at the top leaders in my
life they've been introverted
but the unlikely leader for me that i'm
really focused on is
is almost if you go back to the 18 and
20 year olds that
if you look at giving people equity in
life and the chance
to be a real leader you look at startups
which you're in and you're you're
talking about
some of the people are in there they
might not have degrees yep they might
not have a good education they might
have a background which is very
disadvantaged
but they are brilliant people so the
unlikely leader for me is my real
passion
if i before i die i would love to be
able to see equity increasing in terms
of leadership
welcome to 20 minute leaders just sit
back relax
and learn from the leaders of today it's
a journey each one is different unique
inspiring let's get started
[Music]
this episode is powered by jventures a
community driven vc fund in silicon
valley
in partnership with leumitech sponsored
by hippo insurance
opposed labs touring hillel at stanford
leap and in media partnership with ctec
i'm really excited to dive deep into the
world of coaching in these next 20
minutes and i'm joined by colin hunter
ceo and founder of potential squad
international colin is an author mentor
coach and founder of a business
potential squared
that specializes in creating playgrounds
to disrupt the way people are led
he lives with his family near london but
originally from scotland
and still retains his love for the
scottish mountains and the outdoors
colin and his team work with their
clients to provide leaders and their
teams the chance to as he describes
sail their ship out of the harbor and
test themselves in rougher seas
he is a practitioner and his work in his
book are based on personal experience
and purposeful practice with his clients
colin hunter welcome to 20 minute
leaders how are you
hey i'm very good it's sun is shining
yeah we're heading out of spring towards
summer i'm good i'm in a good place
there
i love it just like the weather is
beautiful we're going to talk about
and we're going to talk about leadership
today and this show you know i call it
20-minute leaders but but really um
today we're going to talk about human
tomb and leadership and what your work
with potential square and what you're
doing there
i think it's going to be a really really
great and i'm excited to learn about
what what you're doing over there
but also about your journey and how you
see leadership from your lenses
and let's start with your ambition to be
an actor and a dancer because i love
that and i have a personal ambition for
that as well tell me a little bit about
that
so i grew up just wanting to be on the
stage
um and i realized i could act but i
did the dancing i have a complete lack
of rhythm
so i felt i couldn't do the combination
so i i left it went off
and actually what i do now with
leadership and with
training and development and other
pieces allows me to be on the stage
quite a bit of the time so
i've realized i'm a dad dancer michael
if you know that expression
so i've given up the dancing but the
acting i can
i love it stage when i want to be but
yeah it's
it's an interest rate i think my career
ended on the stage when i fell in love
with my lead actress who's about four
years older than me
and i think i spent more time actually
looking at her than remembering my lines
in
jean jean dark so yeah at the time so
i love that i love that and so tell me
now a little bit about your entrance to
potential squared and your leadership
experience over there potential squared
where is that even what does that even
mean potential squared i i love the name
already
what does that mean to you
so i i think it comes to the fact that
through all my life i've had a bit of an
impostor syndrome about myself
um but it's been certain people in my
life who have helped me to
find my true potential um and
interestingly enough we
we had a business before we
diverged from that old business and we
were trying to come up with a name
and over many glasses of wine we were
still struggling with the name and my
wife turned ran to me and she said you
need a bit more positivity in your life
in fact positivity squared and it just
at that moment we said potential squared
and then one of my clients said but what
about potential cubed
and i said well i'm scottish so
i'm gonna go with a principle that i you
know under
under promise and over deliver so
therefore potential squared with a
potential cube possibility was what the
name came up with
yeah i i love it and this is potential
for what
it's potential for many different things
i mean the target of what we do we work
with a number of different organizations
accenture city the banks
the pharma companies the large pharma
companies but i have a particular
initiator that i love which is the
unlikely leader now that can be an
unlikely leader at the senior
level who just doesn't doesn't have
belief it can be the introverted leader
i have a hypothesis that the introverted
leader
is the most unlikely leader because they
always think it's about charisma
they think it's about you know the tap
dancing on the stage
um and for me there's a this if you look
at the top leaders in my life they've
been introverted
but the unlikely leader for me that i'm
really focused on is
is almost if you go back to the 18 and
20 year olds that
if you look at giving people equity in
life and the chance
to be a real leader you look at startups
which you're in and you're you're
talking about
some of the people who are in there they
might not have degrees yep they might
not have a good education they might
have a background which is very
disadvantaged
but they are brilliant people so the
unlikely leader for me is my real
passion if i
before i die i would love to be able to
see equity increasing in terms of
leadership
and not just which university you went
to or
you know which school you went to i'd
love to have that that's my passion
yeah i'll i love it and this term
unlikely leader
what is you know the difficulty or the
challenge that is being presented
in this world of unlikely leadership
from your perspective
i think the challenges for me is if you
think about what you're doing and what
you're trying to do and i think about
all the stars we partnered with ideo
so look at design thinking and you know
the thinking about new fresh ideas
and then you think about our education
system our education system is based on
rope we learn my daughters are
learning for exams next door but they're
learning by road they're learning to
pass an exam
rather than dealing with a human so if
you put the human at the center
then it's that ability to connect and
build rapport and empathy
with that person in there now most
people think that a skill of being able
to get on with somebody is not worth
anything
they think it's a you know i'm a
technical i can code is
israel and those have power but we all
know that even if you can code and you
can do technology
having a user-centric and empathic view
on life
is important we also know that scale-ups
and startups do not happen unless you've
got the right people with the right
energy in the right passion in the right
direction so
that's what the unlikely leader is is
about finding those
those almost diamonds in the rough
honing them
and sustaining them so i think you know
the
the talk the discussion around
leadership
and there's a bunch of examples you know
alongside leadership but
it's one of those things that are very
fluffy it's one of those words that you
know is being thrown around a lot and it
loses in some capacity a lot of its true
meaning
and the place where it actually gets
translated and one of the things that i
really love
through these conversations that i'm
doing here is demystifying and actually
grounding
what it actually means so when you're
talking about this user-centric approach
this
empathy human to human leadership that
is not just the ability to code
and do that stuff where does it actually
you know where do you where
from your experience where do people
actually encounter it you know to sort
of ground it a little bit
yeah i think there's many different ways
that people encounter they either
encounter it through adversity
so you know one of the people that that
i admire most is a guy called randy
taylor
and he was an amazing person who in the
in the divided us
at the time was able to bring the north
and the south together in terms of a
view and
there was adversity but he had this
amazing
ability to to gain followers from people
who agreed with him
and followers from people who disagreed
with him in there and
and the principle in here is if we're
going to change things if we're going to
create us a groundswell of change
whether it's in products
buying purchasing whatever else we need
to get followers
and those followers are going to be
influenced by other people so
so leadership the lead ship and in my
language
is about agitation for the future that
is so cool
lead ship yeah yeah so
you've got to be an admiral i mean i'm
reading this great book called be more
pirate
michael and it's brilliant but if you
think about the pirates
they were the founders of equal
opportunity equal pay
all of those things and they did no they
plundered and they did some other stuff
but a lot of the stuff that we're
talking about now was started by the
pirates they had the first female
captains
uh in there so you know that wow lead
ship
it's the analogy and now you know a few
hundred years
uh later in you know in in our in the
tech world and where we are with the
uncle
and unlikely leaders i'm guessing that
it's not as simple as
you know going over a zoom chat or a
simple conversation
you know with a book this is how to
become a good leader it's a little bit
more
complex and humane and it requires a lot
of leadership to
i i guess teach unlikely leadership
what does it actually entail how do you
actually do it playgrounds
playground for me i've always said if
you find the time when people are
happiest you'll find them
in their passionate moments and you know
i started
an idea in my head that my happiest
times with the playground
whether it's on a ski slope whether it's
in the formal playground when i was a
kid at school
uh when i look at you know going on my
bike and going out and you know pushing
myself
so there's a piece in here that you've
got to find a way of creating a
playground
to firstly disrupt people yep because
you've got to push them you've got to
stretch them
and then secondly it's about finding
their passion and their unique piece i
had a
colleague who's a a brilliant guy but
his idea of fun
on a playground was he used to do when
he was working with retail companies
he would spend the night shift stocking
the shelves in retail
and that was his playground to get new
ideas
about how to lead people and he saw
firsthand the problems that people had
and worked and there's many other
leaders who are in that space
find a playground get people to be them
their real self
yeah to have fun to stretch themselves
and then the analogy comes back to the
boating again which is you're getting
people to
almost sail their ship out of the harbor
most leaders that we know in big
corporates
are sailing their boat around the harbor
they're not on they're not searching
rougher waters
most tech startups are searching rougher
water
and how do we get that in you know in in
bread almost into our leaders
in businesses is my passion yeah and so
as a young entrepreneur i definitely
don't want to
go around my own waters what are some
things that i
need to keep in mind as i go about my
journey whether it's my
first startup and i'm leading myself on
my team or whether i'm leading
a hundred people which hopefully
hopefully one day will happen
what what what are things that i can
even ask myself or things that i can do
to even begin working on this question
because it sounds to me
from the side that a lot of the a lot of
the difficulty here is
even uncovering what you don't know or
what your
potential is yeah and that's why you
know
the book that i'm written and has been
published in september it's called be
more wrong
but the principle there in there is
you've got to be i mean i've screwed up
more times in my career
than i you know i used to be able to
care to admit but actually i've found
it's actually a good learning and people
are still listening to me
now i've probably got my detractors i've
got my supporters
but be more wrong so the principle for
me is goes back to
to james clear and atomic habits what
are the systems
that you need to create so what's the
system of followers how do i engage my
people keep them engaged connected
what's the system of energy no i don't
know about you but i
you know in my time when i was younger i
probably burnt the candle at both ends
and i burnt myself out and there's a lot
of people that i coach particularly
going through covert over last year who
have just
they're burnt out they are to the point
of you know they're struggling to
motivate themselves let alone anybody
else
so fit to lead comes in there so there's
a there's a system and energy
but also there's a storytelling piece to
the energy which is
if you're heading towards somewhere and
you know where you're going so my
passion as i said 18 to 20 year olds
equity
that's my true north that i'm heading
towards if i can create a playground
to disrupt that that's going to get me
out of bed in the morning
and it's going to keep me awake at night
and that's an energy
and then if i can indulge two other
things fresh ideas
experimentation so how many experiments
can you run a day
and expect you know in your world eighty
percent of them to fail
twenty percent to be successful and that
i think that the biggest thing
which i come back to is i wouldn't have
got where i was today unless i had good
mentors and good
coaches in my life and i have an
expression which is you can't tickle
yourself
so you can't tickle yourself so you got
to get somebody to do it for you so
unless we can advisory board three
people brilliant
thinkers who challenge me every day so
those would be the four areas
your followers your energy your fresh
ideas
and then your learning and your advisory
board in place those are the four you
need
to be successful yeah how do i even know
if i need to be tickled
how do i know to look for to look for
this help you know i i personally am a
huge believer believer in therapy
and i think that every single person on
this planet
if they have the opportunity to do so
should seek
a therapist whether it's a psychologist
or now i'm learning maybe it's a coach
yeah well i mean i had a coach who was
a brilliant guy he's still a good friend
jamie smart he wrote a book called
clarity
and and i paid the price of a small car
which i'm lucky to be able to afford to
go for three days
and at the the time at the beginning of
the session he puts a flip chart and he
said now write everything that's wrong
with your life
on the flip chart and i wrote three
pages of flip chart
by the end of the three days he went
back to this list and he said
from his work and all he was doing was
getting me to fall out my thinking fall
out my thinking
and it's a bit like therapy it's about
the cars when we're standing in the
middle of the road and all these cars
are heading at us it's a difficult thing
but if we step out the road and just
look and see what's important
we actually realize we have everything
in our control and that's what therapy
is about
it's the ability to to understand
yourself and work in there and therefore
for me a coach is a mentor is somebody
who gets you to move out of the road
where the cars are just about run you
down
and start to think so what's the focus
what are you trying to do
um and we can't do that ourselves mostly
because we're under pressure we're under
delivery targets
or the cash is running out the burn
rate's too high and we're worrying about
whether we're going to run out of or we
need more funding
down the road so that that's the the
principle behind the falling out of
things so jamie smart was a big
thing in my life um and nothing on that
flip chart matters because i have
control of my thoughts
um and therefore my feelings yeah what i
do
but now to deliver and practice that
is that measurable or quantifiable in
any way you know i think that
especially in in the tech ecosystem when
so many things are expected to be
measurable
and quantifiable when you're talking
about leadership
and you're talking about ideas and
experimentation and self-fulfillment
yeah that's not something you can put or
give a number to right i'm guessing
that's that's part of the challenge
and i think this is where james clear
comes in here because he has a quote
which i love which he says
we don't rise to the level of our
objectives we fall to the level of our
systems
and a bit like startups measuring your
systems is more important so
this is a an infinite game it's a life
game that you've got to play
so if i just measure myself i'm going to
sprint for the next six
six months to get this done without
thinking about my longer term goals my
so
the longer term goals are measurable and
i just do something very simple this is
visual so it's a
podcast but i i literally have a habit
tracker and a systems checker
for myself so i can visually measure
have i done
basic things like meditation have i done
basic things like fitness
have i eaten the right things have i
coached have i engaged with my people
um and and the other thing is do they
truly understand me so i do a regular
360 based on our
leadership model um and that's my
check-in and i publish that to everybody
so everybody knows my strengths
weaknesses everything there's
nothing to hide in that that's the
measurable bit of leadership
that's out there when people are seeing
that i'm i'm weak for example bizarrely
i do this for a living
in coaching then they know i'm working
at it yeah
but i coach every day it's just not high
in my conscious state but i'm doing that
putting it out there
i mean as soon as it's measured as you
say people pick it up and they'll start
scar that's cause you don't coach
yeah yeah and so you know i think that
one of the things that
you know or one of the biases that
people have when it comes to coaching
and leadership is
you assume well yeah i it makes sense to
get a coach but
but really i need to be a c-level
executive at a big corporation and i
need to lead
500 people to even begin about you know
seeking
coaching help or even to constitute
myself as a leader
i'm already seeing from your reaction
that that is complete nonsense
but but please tell me a little bit more
yeah yeah
you see i'm not big believer i'm
probably going to alienate quite a few
people i'm not a big believer in the
international coaching federation
because people get an accreditation to
be a coach
um and i've met a few of them and i've
been coached by a few of them just
haven't
really done it for me so i'm a big
believer the people who can coach you in
life are the people who
either have experienced it and have gone
past you and you're further on their
career
or the people who are actually some of
the people you're trying to do so
my daughter has told me more about
dealing with my
people at work she used to come in and
sit at my feet in the office
and she'd be the one kicking me under
the table and going you're a bully
yeah because i'd be doing something in
the office which was
in her view and she's now that's a
teaching moment
when your daughter is calling you a
bully and i'm willing to admit i had a
tear in my eye when i did it because i
suddenly realized
she was she was more perceptive than i
was about the impact i was having on one
of my team
that's powerful yeah so everybody can
coach yeah
un unbelievable and i think that that's
uh
that's really really remarkable another
people that are getting the coaching
yeah how about that the people who are
getting to
into coaching or working well the people
that are look that would need coaching
i'm thinking to myself you know i want
to get to a level where i can
you know look for a coach and feel good
about it how do i know when i'm ready
and how do i know
because i part of my bias says that you
know i need
to lead a hundred people so that i can
justify wanting to get a coach but
really i i want somebody like you to
help me sort out the things that
will give me self-fulfillment and help
me be a better team player and a better
leader
in whatever capacity i need to be in
yeah
so i've got i'm scottish by birth and if
you know anything about scottish people
they're tight with their money yeah
so that's our background that's you know
presbyterian scott
is in there so i've always been looking
for ways to do this in a
in a cheaper way because coaching is
expensive and it is expensive for the
professional coaches
but what i've done is in my business is
i've found that if i can give
opportunities to people to be my coach
if i can give and my advisory board the
three advisors on my advisory board have
never been
executive directors non-executive
directors of businesses before
but they've agreed to come on and have a
go and therefore for two years
two of them have had they've had a
playground to develop their skills about
being a non-executive
director a coach a mentor and they've
been getting feedback on a regular basis
now if you take that down to the lower
level
just think about how many people run
sports clubs at local level and
who are coaches who don't haven't been
trained but they transform lives
so my belief is this there's one book by
michael bunge stanier called the
coaching habit
and he just i wanted i want you to be a
bit more coach like
and that's all we need to do in our life
is just every day be a bit more curious
coach like question open with curiosity
in there and
and that's you know when you're in a
startup you'll be doing the same thing
your m
minimum vial product going out the door
you'll be empathically listening be more
curious to the customer to see whether
you're hitting your targets and your
your metrics same coaching so everybody
can do it
i think the myth of coaching is you need
to sit down at a 90 degree angle for 90
minutes
and be a professional coach you can be
more curious
and you can empower people and and build
people up by doing that that would be my
encouragement
go find yourself somebody who's never
been a coach and say can you just be
curious with tickled me by with
questions for a while
be careful how you say that but you know
that's all we're doing
i love it colin thank you so much 20
minutes go by way way too fast but i
have a few
fun questions for you before we end if
you're ready
yeah ready ready all right so
one of your favorite subjects in middle
school or high school
that's an easy one for me because it was
about the teacher it's geography
so and it's a passion for travel that's
a link
but he did a book on the mezzo journal
in italy and italy is one of my favorite
countries so that's an easy one i had
the passion for the country
passion for him as a teacher geography
yeah
that's great i love it easy one somebody
who you would consider a role model or
somebody that
that inspires you yeah no for me randy
taylor
so that's the we used to sit in a porch
in north carolina
um and it was a you can imagine a wooden
porch rocking chairs
and he used to be able to make me as a
21 year old he must have been
55 he made me feel like i was the most
important and the brightest person in
the world
um and he's passed away now but he was
the guy who was able to just bring the
north and south together
was involved with martin luther king's
march to washington he just
he did so many things but every time i
think that i'm in the wrong i think what
would he do
that's the person inspires me randy
taylor amazing
and what are three words that you would
use to describe yourself or if i would
ask
anybody that you're coaching who is
colin hunter
um so i'll give you one is direct
yeah but it's always partnered with
refreshing
um so i always talk about that i light
fires under backsides
and in bellies in equal measure so
that's two words
and i think the the other one for me is
um
it's a difficult one but i want to
choose three words but i
i pay it forward so the the principles i
give forward
so they the disrupter in me wants to
help other people so
heroes would be the one word i'd give
you that's creating heroes of the people
i work with is a passion for me
yeah colin thank you so so much this was
so enjoyable i have so many more
questions that i can then i came in with
uh and i think that that just shows the
you know the inspiration that i'm
gaining from this i so i really thank
you thank you for your time
thank you for the work that you're doing
with others that this idea of you know
creating heroes paying it forward the
you know the unlikely
the unlikely leader i think that's
that's just really really amazing and
i'm gonna i'm gonna
ponder about that for quite some time
after this episode
so thank you very much for that and stay
safe and stay healthy thank you
youtube michael thank you for having me
on take